Я цілуюся, ти цілуєшся, він, вона, воно цілується, ми цілуємося, ви цілуєтеся, вони цілуються.
- Добре!
У таких невеликих групах, щоб можна було присвятити більше уваги кожному, німці вчать українську.
Після вторгнення РФ до України та хвилі біженців від війни чимало німців збагнули різницю
між українською та російською і навіть стали записуватися на курси української.
Українська мова - то мова, а не діалект. Я люблю українську мову.
Генріху Флінку - 62. Попри поважний вік він старанно робить усі вправи.
На екзамен. - До екзамену. - До екзамену. - Екзамен ауф русіш. До іспиту. - Іспиток. - До іспиту. - До і-спи-ту…
У молодості Генріх вивчав слов’янознавство.
Слов’янознавство в першу чергу означає російську мову,
і ми не сприймали українську як окрему культуру та мову в той час. Тож було нецікаво вчити українську.
Нині ж мова йде саме про те, що українській доводиться захищати себе як культуру та мову,
і ми розуміємо, що було дещо неправильно повністю ігнорувати це та зосереджуватися на російській мові.
Вчителька Оксана Чобанян у березні минулого року разом з донькою була змушена виїхати з рідного Харкова,
а саме з Салтівки, яку тоді нещадно обстрілювали російські війська.
Раніше вона навчала дітей у Харкові німецької, а тепер німців у Кельні української.
Є люди, які цікавляться мовою, і люди, які допомагають українцям
і хочуть спілкуватися з українцями українською мовою, а не російською.
Бо вони вважають, що вивчаючи мову, вони підтримують нас
і дійсно надають такий поштовх, щоб люди, які спілкувалися раніше навіть у Харкові російською мовою,
почали спілкуватися рідною мовою.
Сподіваюся, що війна незабаром буде закінчуватися. - Що війна незабаром закінчиться.
Краще закінчиться, буде закінчена ніхт корект. - Що означає незабаром? - Бальд.
-  за-кін-чить-ся… Ніхт "и" - зондерн "і".
Лише тут у Volkshochschule - в Народному університеті - в Кельні є 4 курси української.
Два очні та 2 онлайн. З квітня минулого року їх уже відвідали або ще вчаться понад 100 людей
у невеликих групах з різним рівнем української.
Як на мене, найважче - це, звісно, перебороти шок алфавіту, тому що всі інші мови, які вони, можливо, знають,
вони всі на базі латині, а тут у нас кирилиця і багато інших букв, які в принципі їм знайомі,
але читаються по-різному. В принципі цей шок ми як українці переборюємо з першого класу
з вивчення англійської мови. Щось схоже. Для дорослих людей це, звісно, трохи важче.
Одне з найважчих слів, звісно, слово, яке вже стало мемом. Це слово паляниця через поєднання букв "иця".
Ці букви їм неймовірно важко вимовляти. Також, звісно, такі слова як полуниця. Те ж саме.
Єва Монес-Отто родом з Польщі, але вже майже 40 років живе у Німеччині.
Коли з’явилася можливість відвідувати курси української, залюбки записалася.
Бо я дуже люблю Україну і я з Польщі, моя хрещена була зі Львова, і я хочу допомагати українцям.
Протягом останніх кількох місяців я працювала як волонтерка з українськими сім'ями у держустановах,
а зараз у гімназії, куди ходить моя дочка, щоб просто швидше контактувати з людьми,
щоб мати можливість краще подбати про них, тому і вивчаю мову.
Ліза Герус має українське коріння: її батько з Одеси, вдома трохи говорили російською.
Але після 24 лютого все змінилося. Для неї тепер принципово говорити саме українською.
Порівняно з німецькою українська граматика важча, вважає Ліза.
В українській сім відмінків, а у німецькій - чотири, це на три більше. В українській мові багато винятків.
Я думаю, що це також дуже складно, що недостатньо просто вивчити правило, а ще є багато винятків.
Вчителька Оксана теж каже, що коли вчила дітей, думала, що німецька складна,
але виявилося, що українська ще складніша.
Зокрема граматика та наголоси. З цим найбільше помилок.
Вам подобАється… - Наголос! - подобАється… - Вам подОбається новий дерев’яний стіл.
Він дуже гарний. - Добре.
Трапляються й кумедні випадки з сучасними гаджетами.
Влітку в нас був інтенсив-курс. Це було три рази на тиждень і працювали по 5-6 годин.
І коли учень читав слово сірий, його Айфон спрацював, тому що спрацювала Сірі.
Він повторював сірий, сіра, сірі і Сірі почала реагувати на його голос. Це було смішно.
Оксана задоволена тим, як її учні та учениці читають і розмовляють.
Минулого року вони ще зовсім цього не вміли.
Каже, коли бачить, що в них все виходить, це не може не тішити.
Твого зошита. - У мене немає твого зошита. - Ліза.
- У його немає свого зеленого светра. - У нього немає свого зеленого светра.
У Народному університеті в Кельні, як і в усій землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія,
попит на українську мову тримається.
Це найбільш густонаселена земля Німеччини,
яка прийняла найбільшу кількість українців - понад 207 тисяч.
Це така цікавинка, щось нове. І, звісно, Україна не сходить зі шпальт газет і телевізійних каналів.
Через це також актуальна тема, на жаль. Мені дуже шкода, що вона актуальна через війну.
Якщо б мене запитали, я б краще не викладала українську мову іноземцям.
Головне - щоб війни не було. Тому що мотив, через який її викладають,
те, що наша країна актуальна, але причина… Я б краще не викладала.
Єва впевнено і без помилок пише ці слова українською.
Коли закінчиться війна, усі вони хочуть відвідати Україну, зокрема Львів.
А поки урок закінчено.
До побачення! - До побачення! . Гарних вихідних!